today I have my grandson so I can't do a
proper video but I wanted to talk to you
guys about two big announcements this
week for Sci-Fi movies or fantasy movies
that I cannot wait to see welcome to Sid
Trek your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
[Music]
Channel so first of all let's talk about
a movie that we talked about over a year
ago go the Highlander
remake there can be only
one with Henry Caville now this has been
a long time of development it's taken
ages but it is now finally happening and
it is officially in proper development
they already have a script they already
have a lot of the work done um regarding
casting Etc Henry cavil is now offici
going to be taking on the Christopher
lamb rooll so he will be the
Highlander um I just hope that they cast
the kgen right and I cannot wait to see
who they cast as Ramirez because I mean
I think now I know a lot of you guys
hate gender swapping characters but I
actually think they should um cast
Michelle yo she can swing a sword and I
just have this basic thing of that in
the story of the Highlander a lot of um
mccloud's motivation was because the
kgen killed
Ramirez and what's more
emotionally challenging or what's what's
what's going to motivate him more than
losing like a father figure losing a
mother figure tonight you sleep in
Hell there can be only
one and I actually think that would have
way more impact in the movie if they did
have Ramirez as like a mother figure but
that's just me get into the comments and
tell me how much you hate that idea
because I a lot of you already do
because I talked about this in the
previous video but anyway another big
announcement today though is that we are
going to be getting another Vin Diesel
movie ridic 4 this is your one
chance take the Lord Marshall's offer
and
bow I bow to no
man now I am a big fan of pitch black I
thought black was great but I
actually think the chronicles of ridik
was way better it was it was really a
mix between fantasy and sci-fi it was a
way more interesting movie it really did
build or start to build a universe that
was really fascinating you pay him 20
Menthol cools to do a surgical shine job
on your eyeballs so you can see you
sneaking up on you in the dark exactly
now in ridic 3 they undid a lot of that
and they B basically in lots of ways
remade pitch black which I thought was a
little bit disappointing remembering the
pitch black had Claudia Black in
it well don't you all have me
surrounded it would be a shame if they
basically just did another monster movie
I'm hoping they could go back and do
something that was closer to the
chronicles of ridic but at least it is
officially announced we are getting it
and another thing that's interesting
before we say bye-bye CU I've got to go
with my grand snip it is interesting
that a lot of these movies are now
getting official announcements we've had
several in the last couple of weeks
could that mean something for
Stargate maybe all of the rumors we're
hearing is that it's coming really close
so let's just keep an eye on it um I
have gone onto the Amazon MGM
distribution website where they release
their press releases I check it every
single day and I will keep checking it
until we get that glorious
announcement if you are new to the
Channel please don't forget to like
subscribe H that Bell notification a lot
of my videos are a little bit better
than this but as I said grome so he
takes priority but if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
uh as always please stay safe I'll see
you next
time
[Music]